Andrew is a post-doctoral researcher, uh
in electrical engineering and computer
sciences at UC Berkeley,
uh working uh doing his post-doctoral
scholar now with Sergey Levine. And he
previously completed a PhD in computer
science at the University of Washington
under the supervision of Kevin Jamieson.
And he also spent time at Microsoft
where he was uh working with Dylan
Foster.
Uh his research focuses on learning in
dynamic sequential and interactive
environments. And much of his work
centers on developing effective and
scalable approaches to exploration with
the goal of enabling efficient uh online
policy improvement.
And uh yes, today we are very excited to
hear uh the latest from Andrew.
Uh please give him a warm uh welcome.
>> [applause]
>> Cool. Yeah,
should I go ahead and get started
already?
Okay. Well,
thanks for the invitation. Yeah, excited
to present to you guys. Um happy to take
questions throughout the talk. Um I'm
not sure how this works in terms of uh
hearing you guys, but if you have
questions I'm sure all of you can handle
that.
Um
so, I want to talk today a little bit
about sort of how do we enable robots to
learn through interaction, through
experience as they interact with the
world. And then moving beyond maybe
behavioral cloning or other approaches
we have to to robot learning. Um and so,
kind of just to motivate this, I want to
just think about um
uh you know, a task that I think many of
us probably have done in our day-to-day
lives. Um
if ironing a shirt, right? And so, I
think probably many of us have ironed
shirts. And how did we how did we learn
to iron a shirt? And you know, it might
look something like the following. When
you try to learn to iron
to to iron a shirt, you might watch some
videos on this. You might sort of
uh internalize something from these
videos, and then you'll go and try to
iron a shirt.
But um
I I I think for tasks like this, at
least for myself, when I tried to learn
to iron a shirt, you know, I didn't
first get it I didn't get it right on
the first try. When I first tried to
iron a shirt, there's some complexity
here. I have to lay out the shirt just
right. You know, I can't I have to make
sure I'm not ironing creases into it,
all these sorts of things. And so,
really to do a task like learning to
iron a shirt, we have to do more than
just watch an internet video on this. We
actually had to like try to do it. We
had to take actions in our environment
and we had to observe how the
environment responded and then sort of
update our behavior accordingly. Right?
And so, learning as humans, learning to
do tasks in the real world like ironing
shirts, it requires some amount of
interaction and experience with the real
world. Right? We can't just internalize
a video and do it perfectly. We actually
have to try it and see what happens.
Um, and so, we might ask, well, how do
we get a robot to do a task like ironing
a shirt?
And we could take, you know, maybe a
similar starting point where we take
some data source, maybe this is internet
data, maybe this is a simulator modeling
a shirt, maybe this is some, um,
humans demonstrating on a robot how to
iron a shirt. And we could take that
data and we could use that data to train
a robot in some way to to iron a shirt.
And we could go deploy this on our
robot.
Um,
and this is, you know, I you know,
maybe a little bit of a simplification
simplification, but a lot of what is
going on in robot learning today sort of
follows a paradigm that looks something
like this, right? We'll train policies
via behavioral cloning, we'll train
policies in a simulation, we deploy them
into the world and we hope that they
work.
Um,
but, you know, we don't actually have
robots in our homes ironing our shirts.
Um, and so, so why is that? And well,
there's maybe a lot of reasons for that,
but I think one thing is that if we look
at these sort of data, there's actually
like shortcomings to each of these. So,
for simulators,
if we have an accurate simulated model
of the world, this is great and we can
often learn in simulation. Maybe Euler's
talked about this at some point in the
course so far. Um, but modeling a an
object like a shirt is actually pretty
complex. Like the dynamics of a shirt
are actually very sophisticated and so,
actually getting an accurate simulated
model that is not trivial.
For something like internet data we
might take a lot of YouTube videos but
we don't actually have grounding for
this this this this this YouTube video
in the physical world. Right? Seeing a
human iron a shirt doesn't tell me the
motor commands I need to send to my
robot to get it to iron a shirt.
Right. In human demonstrations I know
Oyer's talked to someone about like
behavioral cloning and imitation
learning, you know, this is actually a
very, you know,
I think an approach that has led to a
lot of success over the last few years
but it's really expensive to actually
collect enough human demonstrations and
often we find that even as we collect
more there's some amount of distribution
shift between our demonstrations and the
deployment on the robot is we don't
actually still get perfect performance.
And so sort of all of these ways we
might take this like prior data
or our prior information, use it to sort
of train a robot policy and deploy this
in the world somehow it's still not
fully sufficient to actually get robots
that are in the world doing like really
complex tasks that the way that we might
want. And so how do we get there? And I
I want to I want to argue I'd like to
I'd like to suggest that perhaps what we
need to do is think about how, you know,
we as humans learn to do complex tasks
like iron a shirt and think about how do
we actually enable robots to learn from
experience, to learn through
interaction, to not just take some data
source that's fixed and deploy that but
to actually learn as they try things in
the real world. Okay. So a lot of my
work focuses on enabling this, enabling
robots to learn from experience. And so
I want to talk today about some of the
kind of recent work we've been doing
along these directions.
Okay. So what what what how do we enable
robots to learn from experience and what
makes this thing of learning from
experience hard? Um and there's actually
a lot of challenges here but I think the
one I want to highlight today which I
think is perhaps the most fundamental is
the following. Like to enable learning
from experience we need to collect the
experience that distinguishes the
correct behavior. Okay. We usually call
this exploration. Basically what it
means is we try things in the real world
and we sort of learn from that
experience, you know, to to do the right
thing. We call that whole process
reinforcement learning.
Um to maybe it even a little bit more
concrete if we let's think about this
example of ironing a shirt. Um in in
this sort of instructional video says
the first thing you're supposed to do
when you iron a shirt is you spray the
shirt with a spray bottle. Okay? And so,
what do we want our robot to do if we're
trying to get it to learn
to iron a shirt? Well, we would like it
to be playing actions in the real world,
to be interacting with the real world,
to be collecting experience in the real
world that tells it or that shows it
that it should pick up the spray bottle,
right? In other words, if I deploy this
policy here, and it tries a few
different things, and one of these
happens to be the correct thing, then I
can use the information that I collect
from doing this correct thing to learn
the correct behavior. I'll I'll I'll
sort of make this more concrete shortly.
But, we might contrast that with a
policy that looks looks like the
following. You know, if I were to play
this policy in the real world,
um and never actually does the thing
that is correct. It never actually picks
up the spray bottle and sprays that
shirt. And so, if I roll this policy out
in the real world,
it's never actually going to collect
experience that enables learning, right?
And so, when we think about learning
from experience, we think about learning
from interaction. Really, the
fundamental thing we need to do is we
need to understand how do we actually
get the robot to collect this experience
to sort of induce these interactions
that will allow for learning.
Now, so so sort of in some sense, the
goal of exploration, the goal of this
this process is to collect the
experience necessary to learn behavior.
And of course, we want to do this as
quickly as possible.
Okay. So, conventionally
in reinforcement learning, we've kind of
thought about exploration in the
following way. I will drop some agent
into the world, and they don't really
know anything about the world, and
they'll try a bunch of things in the
world until they find the right
behavior, and then they'll update their
behavior accordingly.
So, if we go back to this example,
let's say I I drop the agent into the
world, and let's say that the agent, the
robot, has moved to this state I've
labeled here.
Well, what could they do from this
state? Well, well, in principle, they
could take any possible action, right?
They can move their robot, they can move
their their arm in any possible
direction. So, maybe they take one of
these possible directions,
and they move to a new state.
Right? And now that they're in this
state, they can take any possible
direction. They move to this state, and
so forth, right? And if I roll this out
many times, you know, I might induce
behaviors that look something like the
following.
Right? Now, it's kind of actually
obvious if we think about this. If I
just did this, even if I did this like a
thousand times, or a million times, this
is actually probably not going to do the
right thing.
Right? If I want my robot to say, "Pick
up the spray bottle and spray the
shirt," just taking like random actions
isn't going to actually enable my robot
to do this, right? Um and so, I guess
maybe the conclusion that you
conventionally
when we think about exploration, it
doesn't actually scale to the physical
world. So, learning, actually enabling
robots to learn through interaction,
enabling robots to learn from
experience,
conventionally, in terms of how we
thought about this in the reinforcement
learning community, often doesn't
actually give us very scalable,
efficient approaches. Okay. And so, I
think a lot of the reason that we
adopted these approaches like behavioral
cloning,
um or or learning from simulation, and
stuff like that, is that these
approaches we have to exploration, these
approaches we have to collect useful
experience in the real world are simply
not efficient enough to actually enable
us to learn.
So, I want to contrast, you know, this
sort of exploration, where maybe just
randomly taking actions in the real
world, with how a human might explore.
How would a human explore? Well, let's
say I'm at this state.
Um maybe I would take one of three
actions, right? Sort of I know something
about the world. So, I know maybe the
things I should do in this state is I
should either try to pick up the uh I
should either pick up the iron, or I
should pick up the spray bottle, or I
should pick up the shirt. In other
words, the sort of actions or the
behaviors that I might induce
are significantly more structured and
directed than what a robot would induce.
So, when I go to learn to iron a shirt,
rather than doing these sort of random
behaviors, taking these random actions,
I'm taking very structured, refined
actions, right? And when I go to iron a
shirt, you know, maybe it took me some
amount of interaction, but it took me
like 10 attempts, and then I figured out
how to do it, right? And so, when humans
explore, when humans interact with the
world, we're able to do this much more
efficiently than kind of the way we've
typically done this in reinforcement
learning
before.
Right?
If we compare this exploration to sort
of conventional exploration, we see the
exploration on the right, this is
actually something that I can maybe
efficiently run on my robot, while this
conventional exploration is is simply
too inefficient, too random, too
undirected.
Okay. And so, I want to think a little
bit today about how do we get there?
Like, how do we enable
robots to explore and learn like humans?
So, to answer this, I'm going to take a
little bit of a a detour here. So, I
know Oyer has talked a little bit about
in the course learning from
demonstrations. This is probably maybe
review, but I'll just I'll just I'll
just give you some review just just for
completeness. So, a lot of robot
learning right now, what we're doing is
we're taking human demonstration data.
So, that's we're taking tasks we care
about, we're having humans operate
robots on these tasks, they collect a
big data set of states and actions of
sort of, you know, behaviors
induced by a human to get the robot to
solve the task.
Now, a lot of what we're then doing in
in in robot learning is we're taking
some generative model,
and we're training this model to predict
the action that the human produced at a
given state. And we call this behavioral
cloning or imitation learning, right? We
we're trying to train a policy that kind
of captures the behavior that the human
induces with the hope that the human
uh or or that this this policy will then
will then capture the behavior of the
human to be able to successfully
replicate it on the robot, right?
Autonomously complete the task that the
human has demonstrated.
Okay. So, one detail I want to go over,
I'm not sure how much Oyer has talked
about in this course, is sort of how do
we parameterize this generative model.
This is actually important to what we're
going to get to. And so, very often in
robot learning, what we're doing now is
we parameterize this generative model as
a diffusion or a flow model.
So, what is a diffusion or flow model?
We can just think about a diffusion
model as some generative model
that takes as input some noise, usually
sampled from a standard Gaussian.
It feeds this noise through an iterative
denoising process that then transforms
their denoised this noise into an action
that is sort of trained to be trained to
look like a demonstrator action.
And there's a lot of details here I'm
not going to go over at the moment, but
I think the thing I want to take away
from this is that these BC policies
we're training
sort of most commonly in robot learning
we can actually just think of these as
simply mappings that are sort of noise
to demonstrator actions. And for various
reasons this is turns out to like work
quite well for behavioral cloning.
And it becomes kind of the standard that
I think we do in robot learning.
Okay. So, how do we then how do we
actually think about deploying these
policies? Usually we would do something
like the following. You know, I'm at
some state, my robot is at some state, I
sample a noise, I denoise it to an
action, and then I play the action on my
robot.
I'm at some other state, I you know, I
sample some noise, denoise the noise,
and play the action on my robot, right?
And if I do this many times, you know,
I'll I'll induce sort of a variety of
behaviors on my robot, and maybe
sometimes it
solves the task, sometimes it doesn't.
And often what we observe with imitation
learning is that the behavior policies
we get from this are like sort of
reasonable, but maybe not good enough,
right? Maybe it succeeds 20% of the
time, maybe it succeeds 50% of the time.
But we would really want a policy to be
succeed sort of 90% of the time, 100% of
the time.
Okay. And so, what I kind of want to ask
what I want to think about then is sort
of actually really like a like a
you know, we can actually approach this
question from multiple angles. First, we
might ask, well, if I'm given a BC
policy, can I use this as a starting
point to enable learning from
experience?
Right? Can I use this as a sort of get
this more structured human-like
exploration that I showed you a few
slides ago? And maybe the dual of this
question is we could ask, if I'm given a
BC policy, can I improve that to the
point where it actually succeeds with
sort of like reasonable 90% 100%
success?
Okay.
So, how do we think about doing this?
Well, if we have a BC policy that's been
trained on a lot on sort of a reasonable
set of human demonstrations, we might
have a policy that looks something like
the following. At this state, it might
produce say three options. It might
produce one action that goes to the
spray bottle, one action that goes to
the shirt, and one action that goes to
the iron. In other words, because I
trained this policy on a variety of
human demonstrations, on a reasonable
set of human behaviors, the the action
it's been trained to produce, it's been
trained to mimic the human and not clone
the human at this state. And the human
would produce this reasonable set of
actions. So, the action produced by the
robot or that the BC policy
are this reasonable set of actions.
Now, I also told you a few slides ago
that we could uh think of this BC policy
as simply a mapping from noise, from
Gaussian noise, to demonstrator actions.
Okay? And so, what we could actually
think about doing is we could take this
uniform exploration that we would have
over action space. You know,
conventionally in RL, we would just
explore over action space. We could
shift this exploration to the noise
space by controlling this noise
generation.
And then we could do something like the
following. We could We could maybe try
some noise. We could explore some noise,
and that would lead to an action. It'd
be denoised to an action that goes to
the spray bottle. Maybe some other noise
would be denoised to the action that
goes to the the iron, and some other
noise would be denoised to the action
that goes to the shirt. In other words,
by sort of taking this uniform
exploration over action space, shifting
this uniform exploration over noise
space, and sort of leveraging the
properties of this BC policy, we can
actually induce a sort of very
structured action space output action
space behaviors over sort of reasonable
human actions.
Okay. So, we can actually go one step
further than this, though. So, let's say
we do this. Let's say we place some
noise. We denoise this into an action.
We play this action on our robot, and we
get some feedback that that's the
incorrect action. Well, what we can do
is we explore this one noise. So, we can
shift our exploration distribution now
away from that noise.
Maybe we sample some other noise.
We get We play this action, and this
action turns out to be the correct
action. So, now what we do is we shift
shift our noise to this
to to our exploration to this noise,
right? And we can do this actually using
standard reinforcement learning train,
right? And so in other words, by
modifying the sampling process,
we can now lock onto the correct output
behavior. We can sort of direct our
noise sampling to sample a noise that
will lead to the correct output
behavior.
Okay. And so cumulatively, we propose
this algorithm that does something like
the following. It looks like the
following. Okay, so we have three We can
I mean there are three key components to
this. We have the BC policy, and that's
the initial policy we've trained here,
which we can think about as mapping from
noise to actions, right? Some noise W to
an action A.
I'm also going to introduce this noise
policy, which is what I've controlling
the noise generation that is producing
some noise, and then it'll also induce
what I'll call this noise critic.
Um I think Oyer has talked to you a
little you all about how sort of these
RL algorithms work. So the training for
this is actually very simple. So what
we'll do is we'll just simply roll out
this policy in the following way. At
every step, we'll we'll train our value
function
using sort of standard value function
training to sort of fit the value of
every noise at every state.
Then we'll train the noise policy to
basically maximize this value function.
In other words, it to choose a noise
that gets sort of the maximal value.
And then at every step, what we do is
we'll generate some noise using our
noise value our our noise policy. We'll
feed that noise through our BC policy to
produce some action, and then we'll play
that action on a robot and we'll observe
the state and we'll add that to our data
set.
Okay? And so what we've done here is
we've taken this BC policy and we're
kind of using this as a starting point,
but we're refining this distribution the
BC policy is playing via reinforcement
learning to sort of lock onto the
correct behaviors and get this sort of
very structured exploration, right? And
so if we do this properly, we can
actually direct the exploration to be
this sort of human-like exploration, and
then if I lock in on the correct
behavior, we can induce this sort of
human-like improvement.
Okay. So does it So So So, we ran this
in a variety variety of settings and we
found that actually works quite well.
So, what I'm showing you here is a BC
policy that was just trained on some
demonstrations and the the task here is
pretty simple. We're just trying to pick
up the mushroom and set it on the cloth,
but the BC policy initially sort of
doing reasonably well, but not maybe
succeeding less than 50% of the time.
Um And so, what I'm showing you here is
when we start running our approach by
doing this sort of exploration over
noise space. And what I want to
highlight here is that from the start
the behaviors that are being induced by
this, by trying these different noise
vectors, is actually very structured and
very sort of like human-like almost,
right? It's not succeeding every time,
but every time it's making a reasonable
attempt at sort of exploring
this space of output actions and sort of
inducing these very structured output
behaviors.
And I compare this to sort of the
previous state of the art for real world
robotic RL, which is running an
algorithm that is instead of exploring
over noise space is sort of exploring
over action space, right? So, it's
trying different actions. And the thing
I want to highlight here is that from
the start the exploration behavior here
sort of actually fairly useless, right?
It's trying a lot of things, but most of
these actions is leaning into random
things in free space and it's not at all
interacting meaningfully with our target
task.
Right? And so, it's not actually
collecting useful information
over what we should actually do to solve
this task.
And so,
as as both of these are running, they're
both refining their action
distributions. In our case, we're
refining the noise distribution for the
more previous state of the art, it's
refining
its its distribution in action space.
And what we see is that actually for our
approach after only 25 episodes of
online interaction, it's already locked
onto the correct behavior. So, after a
very small amount of online interaction,
we can already learn to do
right there.
One thing I'll just mention briefly
here, um is that the I'm not going to I
don't I don't have time to go into a lot
of detail on this, but um this approach
actually also circumvents a lot of
technical challenges with running RL on
top of pre-trained behavioral cloning
policies, especially diffusion policies.
You can't actually directly run RL on
them,
um at least not using conventional
algorithms, due to various technical
challenges having to do with how they do
their thing noisy process and their
inability to write down likelihoods. But
so this approach that we're also
actually allows us to incorporate BC
policies within this RL training loop in
a way that really wasn't
impos- possible before.
Okay. And so you can run this on a lot
of studies. We took it on various uh
diffusion policies and VLAs,
um
generally found it works quite well. Um
this it but the BC take up policy that
succeeds something like less than 50% of
the time and boosts this to something
that succeeds, say, 90% 100% of the time
in anywhere from like 30 minutes to 90
minutes of online training. Um
Here's another example policy. So this
is actually not a video I did, but some
researchers at ByteDance took our
approach and they deployed it sort of on
their bimanual setup. Um
and they they were able to get their
policy ba- basically they in in this
example they tried to get they tried to
train a policy simply be be good at
demonstration as they do sort of very
high precision task. Um and what they
found is that trying to train a policy
only on these sort of uh demonstrations
they it succeeded like less than 50% of
the time. It's like training on
demonstrations and human demonstrations
they weren't able to get a policy that
sort of reliably succeeded at this very
high precision task.
But we taken our approach and their BC
policy they were able to refine the
distribution of actions produced by this
policy through the via online
interaction and able to get it able to
get it to actually successfully
succeed sort of close to 100% of the
time. Right? And so I think this just
shows that, you know,
we can go beyond
what BC gives us. We can go beyond what
we can get from these just like
pre-trained policies that were trained
on demonstration and their simulation if
we enable sort of policy through online
interaction. Now, doing this it's really
critical
that we do this efficiently, right? And
so this approach, by leveraging kind of
the structure in the BC policy, we're
actually able to get this very efficient
online exploration and to these
capabilities, but it's actually very
critical that we we do this properly to
enable these capabilities.
Okay. Um here's some more simulated
results. Um
well, you're How am I doing on time? I
have like a second part, but I don't
know if I I don't know if I have time to
go over it. What What is the time? How
much time do I have left?
Uh you're set on time. I think you're
Yeah, you can do like maybe like 5 more
minutes and then questions or
Okay, sure. I'll go quite quickly
through this part. Okay. So, the second
part I wanted to talk about was I said
how do we even think about training
these policies? So, in this first part
of the talk or or this first part I just
assumed, you know, we're given a policy
that's trained via behavioral cloning on
demonstrations, but we might then ask,
"Well, is that actually the best way to
train a policy if I want to then use
this policy for RL improvement?"
Um
So, is BC pre-training So, so we sort of
usually call this initial this initial
phase pre-training. Is this the most
effective initialization to enable
learning from experience?
Um And to sort of answer this, I want to
go back to this example I showed you at
the start of this talk, right? Where if
we have some two policies, say on the
left is one policy and on the right is
the other policy, what we want is we
want this policy to be doing reasonable
things,
say going to the ironing board, but we
want to make sure that the behaviors
that are needed for improvement are
actually in distribution for this
policy.
And so, if we prefer the policy,
pre-trained policy A to pre-trained
policy B because
pre-trained policy A is actually
interacting with the spray bottle, which
is what we want, while pre-trained
policy B is not. And so, if we roll out
pre-trained policy A, we'll collect
experience that allows us to learn,
while pre-trained policy B does not
collect this experience. And so, when I
pre-train a policy, what I really want
is that when I ensure
that it collects the experience
necessary for enabling improvement.
Okay. And so, the first thing we might
ask, "Well, is BC if we if we just train
a policy in the standard way we train
policies, is that going to be sufficient
to enable learning from experience?"
And what we see is that if we if we we
look at this sort of BC process, let's
say take some demonstrator, If they
collect some set of demonstrations, and
then I train a policy on those
demonstrations. And let's say this case
that it just so happens that the BC
policy hasn't actually or the
demonstrator hasn't actually
demonstrated the the behavior picking up
the spray bottle. Maybe we just haven't
collected enough demonstrations yet.
What happens when I do BC pre-training
is that I simply get a policy that
doesn't express that behavior. And so if
I just pre-train with BC, what I'm doing
is I'm just directly fitting the
demonstrations. So if I'm perfectly
trying to fit these demonstrations, and
so doing that doesn't necessarily give
me a policy that is going to express the
behavior needed for improvement. If the
demonstrations don't collect don't sort
of span the right behavior, I'm simply
stuck.
All right. So if I want to use my BC
policy on my pre-trained policy as a
starting point for RL, this sort of says
that using BC is maybe not sufficient.
And we show we can show formally that it
actually can happen. I'm not going to
sort of go into a lot of detail here.
Um but basically BC is maybe actually
not going to express the actions needed.
How could we fix this? Well, one thing
we might do, and this is often what we
do in part, is that we take the BC
policy and we just add some noise to it.
Right? At every step, with some
probability I'll take the BC play the BC
action, and with some probability I'll
play another action. Maybe maybe a
random action. And it might look
something like the following. If I do
this, what I see is I actually do get I
can induce the right behavior.
Now the issue here is we can actually
show that there's a fundamental
trade-off between the exploration we'll
induce and the performance of this
policy. Okay. So if I explore from this
policy, I can express a lot of
behaviors. I can do a lot of things, but
I'll actually decrease the performance
significantly.
If I reduce the exploration, then I I
will maintain the performance, but I
won't actually be able to express a lot
of new behaviors. And so why is this?
Well, if we think about this first case,
when we explore a lot, we're actually
over-exploring in some sense. Basically,
we know from our demonstrations
that we should go to the to the ironing
board.
But by adding So by adding exploration
in this early phase, we're sort of
deviating from the behavior we know to
be correct, and we're
we're making the policy worse.
In the second case, we're actually under
exploring. So, now I'm not exploring
significantly. I'm getting to the iron
in the board, but I'm not actually
adding that much expressivity to enable
learning again at this point after the
iron.
Okay. So, what do we do to get around
this? Um
I don't think I have a whole lot of time
just to go into a lot of detail here,
but the kind of key idea behind this is
thinking about the this pre-training
process rather than just in terms of BC
from a more like Bayesian angle. And in
particular, trying to understand how do
we actually quantify our uncertainty
about the demonstrator's behavior, and
training a policy that adjusts its
exploration proportional to the
uncertainty in the demonstrator's
behavior, right? And so, we can actually
show formally I I don't have time to go
into to sort of describe this in detail,
but we can we can show formally that you
can actually take this these
demonstrations, and rather than just
fitting them with BC, you fit sort of a
an estimate a policy that estimates the
uncertainty of the demonstrator's
behavior, and then this will actually
scale the exploration of this
pre-trained policy proportional to to
sort of how uncertain they are. And what
this allows us to do, it allows us to
lock into the correct behavior when we
know what the demonstrator will do
while ensuring that we get sort of
expressive performance when we don't
know what the demonstrator will do.
Okay. So, I'll just skip ahead to the
result. We we took here a policy that
was trained on demonstrations where the
goal is to pick up the corn instead of
in the palm. And I'm showing you on the
left the BC policy,
and on the left our right our policy,
which is sort of trained in this way
that sort of takes into account our
uncertainty of the demonstrator.
Now, it turns out that BC both of these
kind of do roughly the same in in this
case, both mostly fail. They sort of
aren't able to actually successfully or
reliably pick up the corn and set it in
the palm. But, what we did is we we took
an online RL approach, and we ran an
online RL on top of these policies. And
what we found is that we weren't able to
actually effectively improve the BC
policy. It sort of gets stuck below 50%.
Well, our policy we're actually able to
improve up to 75%. And so generally we
see this to be true that if we train
policies in this way,
we can get a pre-trained policy that has
the same performance as a BC policy,
but after online improvement we're able
to get a much more effective policy than
simply trying to fine-tune the BC
policy. Okay? And so kind of the
conclusion of this is that rather than,
you know, when we're thinking about
online RL, when we're thinking about
training our policies to explore,
we both need to think about how to
actually get good algorithms that can
sort of learn and explore online, but we
also need to maybe investigate even how
we're doing the pre-training in the
first place, how we're leveraging this
knowledge we have in the first place.
And if we think about that and sort of
do it use it correctly, we can actually
get approaches that are able to even do
even better at enabling learning from
experience and sort of enabling you to
use real-world capabilities that maybe
we wouldn't otherwise have gotten to.
Okay, I'm going to close there. I think
I'm out of time, so I don't know if
there's
uh time for questions, but happy to take
a few if the folks have any.
>> [applause]
>> Yes, questions.
Hey, I'm going to have a quick question.
So like this is still on trajectory
level, right? Like um and I'm just
wondering how the performance compares
against Pi 0.6 star where they kind of
um determine like a good action and a
bad action within the same trajectory
and to like supersede any human
demonstrated trajectory.
Um and if you think that
that like
making the policy better based on
exploration on the same trajectory will
be good enough for most tasks.
And um also I'm wondering how exactly
the value function is trained. Um is it
just like the predicted future will like
sparse reward or is it like or like what
do you do you think there's like more
value in using VLM as a base critic like
they did in the Pi 0.6 star paper?
Yeah, um so I guess that we haven't none
of these have we compared against Pi 0.6
star, which I think all both of these
papers came out before that paper. Um
uh
I think the
On the question of critic, I think
whether or not you want to use a VLM or
something like that probably really
depends on the goal is. If you want to
do like single task, I think you want to
improve on like a single task, I think
using like a VLM critic is overkill. Um,
I think if you want to do sort of more
of multi-task language condition
critics, then probably something like a
VLM makes sense. Um, and that was more
kind of the regime that they were
operating in
for the Pi0.6 star paper. We're kind of
more operating in a regime where we're
just looking at a single task. So, I
think it just depends a lot on the
situation.
I think we are doing um
Uh, I I guess that maybe they don't
fully understand this question on like
trajectory level
exploration or whatever. Um,
like in some sense I would say this is
still trajectory
level and that well, I mean, we're just
running sort of standard RL. Like the RL
training we're running is actually not
that different than what they're running
in the Pi0.6 star paper in terms of like
both of them are just training like
value functions in some way. Um
Uh
Uh, we're kind of I guess maybe the key
difference in terms of how we're
thinking about this and these approaches
is where we're not just training an
advantage condition policy. So, what
we're training is a standard policy, but
then we're refining it with some other
policy to produce sort of the right
actions. Whereas the Pi0.6 star paper,
they're trying to train this like single
policy that's conditioned on these
advantages that is like going to these
advantages that will lead it to the
right behavior. Um,
I think I think there's a lot of work
that needs to be done trying to
understand actually which of these
approaches is the most effective when. I
think there may be a regime where
advantage conditioning is the right way
to do it and maybe a regime where it's
more like direct RL is the right way to
do it. Um, and I think we don't actually
have like a very good understanding at
the moment uh of that question.
Tiffany. Uh, thanks for the great talk.
I had a question about the DS RL.
Actually, it only works if the BC policy
is actually steerable via the initial
noise and sometimes this is not the case
depending on how you train the policy.
And I was wondering if you try to steer
policies based on the state because
usually policies are actually more more
sensitive to this.
Yeah, that's a good question. We haven't
really tried that. I think it'd be
interesting to look into something of
that flavor. Definitely becomes a little
bit tricky because if you you perturb
the state too much, you know, you might
make the policy produce just like bad
actions.
Um so, I think there'd be things you'd
have to be careful with there, but I
think it would be interesting to look
into and we haven't tried that.
Thanks.
Anyone else?
Okay, then let's thank the speaker
again.
>> [applause]
>> Thanks a lot, Andrew.
Yeah, thanks for the invite.
I will talk to you later. Yes, see you.
Bye.